poser cette question que tout le monde
attend je tape attendre plus longtemps
coumba oui série a tu manges et la
sarine je te jure sur tout ce que j'ai
de plus cher comme on dit chez nous un
sonic et où elle l'a une bulle ex
héritiers pas manger j'ai pas mangé
kombouaré spectateurs pub et je vous
jure j'ai pas mangé je suis sorti la
première de la réunification comment tu
veux que je mange là je vais mener ma
petite enquête koumba koumba
je vais donner des éléments aux
téléspectateurs qui nous regardent qui
se pose la seule et unique question qui
a mangé
et à manger
coumba vous êtes arrivés sur l'île
et vous êtes reparti
avant les repas avant avant les repas
kandestin effectifs j'ai mené mon
enquête elle fait coumba était déjà loin
oui effectué pendant que les autres sont
chiffrées à
grand renfort fait confiance mais de
roue d'or et de port salut c'est
confirmé c'est une balle en raison vous
n'avez pas manger car j'ai mené mon
enquête combat vous êtes libre
merci beaucoup de mavuba la santé mais
elle n'a pas mangé je le sais
aujourd'hui merci combat d'être là hier
quoi son nom est sorti j'étais un homme
baisser pour son nom et sans raison
balazs et c'est maintenant aller alors
elle est super même si mes amis c'est
réellement une armée parce que à mon
avis il ya eu il ya des gens qui ont
dicté avait mangé mais tu mets ça ne
peut que ça concorde paca les dates de
ce chrono de l'agenda manger
chronologiquement tu ne pouvais pas
manger c'est comme si vercingétorix
sorte avec david guetta
chronologiquement ça ne marche pas voyez
ou pas donc je te le dis est ce que tu
avais entendu parler quand même de cette
tricherie sur l'île et de ses repas
clandestins je sais qu'on voit là ça
commence à faire beaucoup là le savait
oui oui effectivement je la samba oui
mais là ça je sais que tu me diras toute
la vérité sur noir tel joueur ne peut
cracher sur benjamin
non mais c'est vrai tu le savais ça je
le savais mais comment ça se fait sans
rigoler cette année qui a tant de gens
qui mangeaient dans koh lanta mais parce
que maintenant ça avec le nom d'un
restaurant nous collons là mais moi moi
j'avais envie que j'avais envie de dire
que peut-être que comme on est des
aventuriers aguerris la prod avait bois
pour tous les vices nous on avait le
tournevis son bar à les feintes et puis
je pense que la fraude avait une grande
confiance en nous en se disant les
candidats on va pas les flics et ils
sont assez grands c'est des vrais
aventuriers vont pas aller chercher à
tricher mais s'alimenter c'est le besoin
primaire donc je pense que ce qu'ils ont
mal calculé leur coup et puis moi j'ai
envie de dire que la prod également eu
aucune animosité contre 8 chez les ados
rencontrèrent mais eux aussi ont merdé
dans l'histoire allait mettre plus de
surveillance en vérité moi là on va les
empêcher
ça vous avez tongiens se retrouver on va
chercher comment tu as été mise au
courant de ces repas
frugal moi j'ai été mise au courant à la
fin à la faim ce conte avant même de
rentrer le prendre l'avion pour paris
c'est au courant matin qu'est ce que tu
as dit je ne peux pas dire et à la prime
de confidentialité
ah ah ah la la peine de contenu solide
et je la fais ce qui est coincé dès 2012
c'est bien ils veulent et sagement brut
je les donne
pendant qu'ils attendent je dois me je
ne donnerai rires
je donnerai donc non donc tu savais que
ça démange et ouais ça va